rumors are picking up steam that tesla
is designing a smartphone called the
model p or pi it all began in february
2021 when the youtube channel adr studio
uploaded a video titled tesla model p
concept so is there any truth to this
rumor and if so what can we expect from
this new tesla smartphone stick around
as we take a look at all that in this
video first of all does it make sense
before i go into the phone specs it
makes sense to ask does it make sense
for a company like tesla which is solely
focused on manufacturing eclectic
vehicles to make smartphones i've given
this a fair amount of thought and
strangely enough i think it does make
sense not when you're looking at tesla
in isolation but when you consider
elon's overall vision with all his
companies it makes perfect sense let me
explain from the beginning elon has
always said he focuses on three crucial
civilization defining problems internet
access sustainable energy and space
exploration now i know the idea of a
personal communicator sounds out of
place among these massive endeavors but
think about it if elon could put at
least two of these concepts at work
together that is internet access and
sustainable energy into a phone that
would be a perfect recipe for a
generation defining products like the
iphone was 15 years ago a phone that can
access information anywhere on the
planet without any connectivity hassles
using the starlink network that spacex
is already hard at work making a reality
and a phone that can use renewable
energy and superior battery technology
to give its users if not unlimited
significantly better energy efficient
performance both technologies that tesla
is currently working on and since
processor display and camera performance
is peaking on all smartphones a topic
that i discussed extensively in my video
why i think the iphone 14 will be a bad
buy manufacturers and inventors need to
come up with some revolutionary changes
to bring about a paradigm shift in the
smartphone industry and if he can merge
the two technologies as discussed
earlier i think maybe just maybe elon
could quickly take over the smartphone
market from apple and unleash the next
revolution i wouldn't put it past him so
now that i've established that it does
make sense for tesla to enter the
smartphone market let's check out the
purported features of this new phone
model p or pi
at this time the tesla model p is
nothing but a concept sorry to burst
your bubble if you thought we might get
a tesla phone soon tesla or elon have
never come out and said anything about a
smartphone or whether there is indeed a
project underway to design such a phone
however as a tech junkie it's always fun
to speculate and if tesla was secretly
working on a smartphone concept it's
even more fun to imagine this new
phone's features in all fairness the
2021 youtube video by adr studio was not
the first time i heard about tesla's
plans to enter the smartphone industry
in fact way back in 2013 there were
reports that tesla was working on a
phone but as we all know that phone
never saw the light of day and the
project was eventually scrapped but
adr's slick video has sent the internet
into a tizzy in a year and a half that
this video has been out various outlets
and experts have speculated about the
purported features of the new tesla
phone so what might those features be
the phone looks strikingly similar to
the iphone 12 pro max in the video with
a few key differences first of all the
camera module is entirely different it
houses four cameras arranged in a square
similar to the galaxy s20 ultra except
that it's placed at the center of the
back case leading many experts to
believe that the space inside might be
optimized to fit in a bigger and better
battery pack or advanced communication
modules although the four camera setup
is nothing new many people have
suggested that the tesla model p's
cameras would perhaps serve a more
complex function than just taking
pictures for example they may work in
conjunction with tesla's fsd software
and act as a second set of eyes for
tesla's ai neural net actively learning
from what the phone user sees to carry
out custom functions i know it sounds
like a long shot but think about it in
essence that's what a tesla car does it
uses its cameras and sensors to learn
about its environment so why can't the
camera on your smartphone be leveraged
to do something similar the idea is
totally plausible if implemented imagine
the additional data the tesla ai can
have at its disposal this will also
allow the phone to be better integrated
with all tesla car models which also
makes perfect sense allowing users to
have more controls through the tap of a
button maybe users can control features
such as locking unlocking temperature
multimedia navigation and even an ai
show first service which tesla has
already claimed to be working on with
their robo taxi announcement all this
might lead to the eventual demise of the
big display inside all tesla models
future users may only need to sync their
car to their tesla phone and let the ai
take care of the rest won't that be nice
moving on from the ai camera it also
seems like the model p's back case has
something interesting going on this has
led many people to suggest that it is
some sort of a secondary display that
can be used for notifications or other
quick actions we have seen this on a few
phones like the xiaomi mi mix alpha but
i believe if tesla were to do something
with the back case it wouldn't be some
gimmicky display but rather something
more sophisticated and game-changing
like a high-efficiency solar panel that
makes the phone fully renewable portable
solar panels have been around for ages
but they are usually clunky and not very
efficient you see the efficiency of
solar panels currently is defined by the
density and surface area if tesla can
crack the efficiency problem which it is
currently working on there is no reason
to doubt that we might see smartphones
with built-in solar panels very soon
this coupled with a smaller version of
tesla's new 4680 battery cell under the
hood can make the tesla model p a
genuinely revolutionary smartphone a
phone that can automatically charge
itself and efficiently discharge power
based on usage and other functions at
best it can make the smartphone totally
free of external charging and at worst
it can dramatically extend the battery
life of the device beating all
competitors into the dust either way
seeing a smartphone with a solar panel
on its back will be quite something
first of course tesla would need to
figure out how to efficiently use panels
as most people keep their smartphones
tucked away inside a pocket or a purse
but that's a problem for another day the
next significant feature of the phone
would be its ability to communicate with
the starlink network when fully
operational it would mean that if you
own a tesla model p you'll have access
to the internet anywhere on this planet
gone will be the day of you having to
point your smartphone to the skies to
get that extra bar of connection in
areas with spotty coverage now you can
enjoy high-speed internet everywhere a
few theories are floating around that
elon plans to send this phone along with
humanity to mars while i fully support
that idea i'm not sure you can use a
regular smartphone in extreme space
conditions for starters the intense
radiation and heat are enough to blow it
to smithereens plus the shielding and
cooling requirements for a communication
device in space can't be packed within a
sleek looking design at least based on
our current technology but then again we
are discussing the future here so who
knows and finally i have saved the most
remarkable feature of the tesla model p
for last with elon investing millions
into his neuralink venture this phone
might just be the first smartphone on
earth that is fully controllable by
human thoughts yes you heard that right
neuralink has already developed a fully
functioning prototype of an implantable
brain machine interface that will allow
humans to control machines using
thoughts the final output of neuralink
along with the brain implant will be a
machine that can communicate with that
implant in this case that machine will
become the most common machine that
humanity uses to communicate a
smartphone if tesla model p manages to
achieve this feat it would be a paradigm
shift in how we humans interact with our
devices first came the computer mouse
that made scrolling and clicking a
reality then came the touch screen that
made haptics like 3d touch and gestures
a reality with tesla model p and
neuralink the next mode of interaction
will be thought control and brain
machine interface now you tell me if
that would bring about a revolution or
not would you like to see tesla enter
the smartphone industry and make all of
this a reality let us know in the
comment section below if you enjoyed
this video please leave a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel for more such
tech related videos see you in the next
one